here locally a leader for the romanian
community is also spreading a message of
unity as that war continues christian
gossip is joining us now live in studio
with more on that christian that's right
well prayers and support you can't go
wrong with that right so that is exactly
what leah roberts is asking from her
romanian community right here in
southern nevada now we caught up with a
local leader at a place where she says
many go looking for answers
this is the main reason we come to
church in the first place or no war we
come here for healing we come here for
hope inside these church walls i met
leah roberts she is the honorary consul
general of romania in las vegas and says
like everyone else all eyes are on the
war the biggest concern
needless to say is the one of
going over i mean the russian troops
coming over to
moldova and then the romania which
again it is a country of
part of the nato robert tells me there
are about 25 000 romanians in the valley
and while many have different faiths
those who come to saint george and saint
dmitry romanian orthodox church near
jones and charleston are ready to help
we know that there are about two hundred
thousand
refugees from ukraine that
came to romania and there are sixty
thousand families that open their homes
in romania for all these people as
billions of dollars in u.s aid are now
headed to help ukraine
robert says this is not a solution but a
relief now she prays inside this church
that others in the community can stand
together the main the main reason is to
emanate some kind of hope in this
certain people to leave here with a
lighter heart and lighter minds in in
order to be able to cope with what is
coming whatever is coming
well roberts added that as consul
general of romania people need to be
united more than ever donate and help as
much as possible christian casa is live
local now